qui est passa l'offensive contre les
organisations religieuses en lien avec
la Russie présente sur son territoire
une enquête sur leurs activités et
lancées a annoncé le président volody
mirzelinski jeudi soir
le Conseil de sécurité nationale et de
défense à charger le gouvernement de
proposer au Parlement un projet de loi
pour rendre impossible les activités en
Ukraine des organisations religieuses
affiliées au centre d'influence au sein
de la Fédération de Russie
l'objectif limiter les activités de
l'Église orthodoxe dépendante du
Patriarcat de Moscou est souvent accusé
de coopérer secrètement avec la Russie
le but serait aussi de déterminer si
cette branche moscovite de l'église
était autorisée à exercer ses activités
dans la Lore des grottes de qui Yves ce
trésor national niché au cœur de la
capitale
un site déjà perquisitionné il y a une
dizaine de jours et où les forces
ukrainiennes ont saisi plusieurs
milliers de dollars et de la littérature
pro russe
l'Église orthodoxe russe a ouvertement
apporté son soutien au Kremlin depuis le
début de l'invasion comme la souvent
exprimé son patriarche un ancien membre
du KGB est proche du président Vladimir
Poutine
aujourd'hui le Dombas et la ligne de
front pour la défense du monde russe ce
monde russe n'est pas seulement la
Russie c'est partout où vivent des gens
qui sont élevés dans les traditions de
l'orthodoxie et de la morale russe en
mai dernier l'Église orthodoxe
ukrainienne rattachée au patriarcates
Moscou a rompu ses liens avec l'Église
russe elle a toutefois perdu la
confiance de nombreux Ukrainiens face
aux accusations de collaboration avec
l'envahisseur